somebody mentioned during the call that
divorce laws make red pill necessary I
think that was maybe you chase it
sounded yeah that might have been me
yeah yeah like what's actively being
done by the Christian pill and by you
know guys in your community to fix the
uh corrupt divorce court system that's
that's a great question I mean uh this
is big within the Christian nationalism
movement so there's a there's a uh what
is he like a state senator or something
his name is Dusty ders he's in okah
and they they're making no fault divorce
illegal in Oklahoma as well as Banning
abortion and now they're working on
Banning pornography in Oklahoma as well
but like that's that's huge um Christian
nationalists are big into this no no
false Force needs to be destroyed okay
so what is the definition of no fault
divorce as you understand it as far as I
understand it goes it's basically you
can just decide that you want to get a
divorce and then you can just do it
fault right yes okay so let's say that
you can prove
fault or you manufacture fault right you
know that then becomes the other problem
and the law still exists as like
removing no fa divorce is maybe a step
in the equation in a in a for Direction
but I think like reforming divorce law
family law in general the way that it
operates is a more significant movement
towards something that's going to
encourage guys to wife up them
hoes dude I I completely agree look I'm
28 years old and like I don't know squat
about family court and divorce laws and
how all that stuff works but I do know
that it's a problem and I know that back
in like I don't know I think like the
40s or the 50s if you wanted to get a
divorce from your spouse uh I think in
much of America you had to actually
build a a legal case and take it before
a judge uh for them to even approve it
like it was it was a hefty process and
you had to bring evidence for why the
divorce should happen so on and so forth
that like I don't know I don't fully
understand why we went away from that
model and you said something earlier in
this conversation you said
that women are I can't remember how you
put it but they're they're they have
advantages in family courp they're
encouraged to div behave badly yeah
encouraged to behave badly and that
works in their favor and in family you
want to walk you through some of the
things or yes yes please absolutely okay
so the the the um you know the notion of
Child Support so let's deal with that
first um the custodial parent that has
the children so in Canada you know for
example where me and Mike live um if you
have the kids about 41% of the time
sorry 41% of the time or more one of the
parents then it's considered shared
custody if Mom has the kids 60% of the
time or more than she's a custodial
parent she gets to make unilateral
decisions she can do whatever she wants
basically you know if she meets uh hot
dude across the country and wants to
move 4,000 kilometers away uh she can
take the kids and go um she can initiate
medical procedures without the father's
consent um any kind of medical procedure
you know she can there's there's all
kinds of that has you know happened
like hyphenate the last name she meets
another guy he wants to adopt the kids
change the last name hyphenate the last
name stuff like that and I mean that's
just one example of one of the things
that women are encouraged to leverage
and on top of that here's the other
problem too
um we know children do better with
access to both parents and you know good
equal parenting is is going to produce
more useful members of society um women
that are getting all of these custody
orders are doing so not just to control
but also for enrichment um friend of
mine was I think kid was like four or
five or something like that when they
got uh when they parted ways uh he cited
you know the affordability for daycare
and uh clothing and extracurricular for
like swimming lessons for tiny taught
class and stuff like that it's about a
th000 bucks a month you we call it a,
bucks a month was what they were
spending but based on his income the
child support tables would have
compelled him to pay over $4,800 a month
now that's not for the child's need
that's just because the government
cooked up some table that said well if
you make x amount of dollars and this
percentage needs to go to the child it
doesn't maintain the child's lifestyle
it enriches the mother's lifestyle so it
thereby encourages mothers who are
getting divorced and by the way also
untying the not most of the time to
fight for primary custody because they
don't just get control and the kids they
also get more of his money so that's
just an example of one incentive that's
in place in family law now that's in
Canada there's there's certain states
where that exists and others where they
don't like for example in Florida
Kentucky Michigan and California you
have default 50-50 divorce
uh so custody if you want to be the
primary custody or the primary caregiver
you have to prove that the other parents
basically a degenerate piece of
right like he's a you know she's a
prostitute he's a cocaine dealer it' be
bad for the child to be with the parent
equal time child should be with me um so
there's lots of and this is just one of
like hundreds like there's lots of
mechanisms in place that they've written
in a family law to you know and I'm
doing this in quotes obviously for those
that are listening but to protect and
preserve the the interest of the
children and the mother right and it's
like okay is it explicit to protect the
interest of the mother like is there
anything well that's the argument that
they use it's you know like children
need their mother and it you know
protects the interest of the children
but but if the children's like cost to
maintain their lifestyle in
extracurricular school like uh school
clothing is like $1,000 at that time why
do tables exist that compel men to pay
you know four five times six seven times
more than what they're paying when
they're married and then they don't get
a say and how to raise a kid anymore
because she's got control right so it it
it robs fathers of the ability to be a
father and parent their own child like
many men these days find themselves in a
scenario where after they get divorced
if she's a primary custody uh parent uh
the new guy whoever she's banging now
spends more time with with his kids than
he
does right so that's just that's just
one angle that encourages women to
behave badly through family law I don't
think guys contemplate that and
understand a lot of these narratives
until they actually live it like you're
28 years old you haven't heard of some
of these things right yeah well and this
is this is exactly why I made the point
in the space last night that this is why
the red pill is important for men
because there's a lot of hoes out there
that are totally untrustworthy and
aren't virtuous that will completely
screw dudes over and guys will get
blindsided by this stuff and it it ruins
your life you know uh and that's that's
why I see the red pill as very necessary
for men nowadays um I think one of one
of the problems that I see though is
that it's fundamentally a reactionary
movement and what you're
describing is extremely problematic and
all those laws in my opinion over a long
span of time need to be reformed and
they can be reformed and I guess my
question that's the target the target
should not be no fault
divorce as in eliminating no divorce
right yeah forget about no fault divorce
I mean if you remove the incentives to
get divorced yeah for women to untie the
knot then no fault divorce will sort of
take care of itself she's not going to
want to untie the knot and cheat on him
to take the kids and get his money and
half stuff so yeah I guess that that so
that was going to be my follow-up
question is like what do you think what
what what would an
ideal Family Court law situation look
like to eliminate all of those
incentives like like what's what's the
most ideal situation to protect men uh
so that we can reverse a lot of this
stuff so it isn't so dangerous for guys
to get married you know the pendulum
swung in the opposite direction there
was a time when men would get divorced
where they would have custody see the
kids yeah I'm pretty sure that you're
aware of that it's you know it's talked
about you know the old books um do you
know what the purpose of marriage is by
the
way from a secular worldly perspective
or from the biblical perspective from
well it's been studied there's this G
her named Stephanie CS she wrote a book
called uh a history of marriage and she
wanted to figure out why you know people
been getting married so she was going
through court records Diaries you know
religious uh Records all these entries
you know throughout history and it was
determined that the reason why people
have gotten married in the past was was
the acquisition of in-laws you know it's
uh suggested that when there was no
State when there was no government when
there was no fire services and policing
and schooling and medical system you
would want to integrate your large
family with her large family and you
would have access to those tools and
resources and you'd have access to the
muscle and the education and the people
with you know certain things that you
may not have in your own family so it
was a blending of the F families right
so it wasn't about love it wasn't about
religion it wasn't about any of those
things according to all the data that
was collected from all those uh texts it
was just about the acquisition of
in-laws how far back does that go you
know that's a good question I read that
book a few years ago and I can't
remember but I think it was as far back
as she could find the records right
because uh you know the original concept
of marriage comes from this idea of
becoming a one flesh Union under God to
have this container spiritual container
to have F to have a family and to be
fruitful and multiply and to not create
multiple multi multigenerational
distress there's this argument for pigy
from these Bible Bros which makes no
sense because Solomon and David all bore
the wrath from their actions and there's
nowhere in the Bible that explicitly
promotes that although there were those
examples in the Old Testament um so yeah
it'd be curious to know how far that
goes back because from a Biblical
perspective that sounds like a purely
secular uh compilation of of data I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out